meanwhile the European Union the EU is
considering a new travel ban on America
a ban on Americans traveling to Europe
in response to coronavirus cases Fox
panel contributor dr. mark Segal joins
us with the latest on this dr. thanks
for coming on
hi Tucker let's take this back to March
11th when Italy passed 10,000 cases and
in the United States here we had 1,100
confirmed cases and President Trump
issued that travel ban where he
basically said 26 countries stretching
from Iceland to Greece you couldn't
travel to here from Europe and you know
what the European Union did they were
horrified they called president Trump
irresponsible but looking backward we
see actually that most of our cases at
least on the East Coast came here from
Europe because they were receiving cases
from China and then on into the United
States look today at June 23rd when we
have 2.4 million cases and Italy has
1/10 of that now the European Union is
getting ready to reopen their borders
guess who may not be on the list the
United States guess who is on the list
Tucker China and the European Union is
calling our handling of the coronavirus
of failure well maybe it's a failure
because when we thought we had 1,100
cases we probably had over a million or
at least several hundred thousand by
that point now you could make a case for
this being public health on the part of
the European Union they're saying that
if you live in a state or a region where
there's less than 50 cases per 100,000
people maybe then you could travel to
the European Union maybe then you could
travel to Europe well let's see now
Montana South Dakota Wyoming you're in
New York Texas Arizona California you're
out so I think that this will have a
huge impact on our economy and I'm
actually wondering whether this could
have something to do with President
Trump this week saying that foreign
workers with visas are not allowed into
the country could this be retaliatory
possibly could it be public health
whatever it is it's not the tone they
sounded back in March when they were
harmful
at our travel ban at a time when
thousands and thousands of cases were
coming here so I have a message for the
European Union tonight
how about remembering what we did for
you in the middle of the twentieth
century
Tucker yeah I think that's worth
remaining this is global power politics
at work as always
under the masquerade of public health
dr. Siegel thanks so much for explaining
that
good to see you tonight thank you